if we think back to probability right in
probability when you have separate
events you add them right what's the
probability of getting two heads or two
tails you can't have if you're flipping
two coins you can't have both in the
same time so you would add those
probabilities but what's the probability
of getting two heads well you leave them
together at the same time you need the
consonants and the vowels to make your
word right so that's why I'm going to
multiply these what does that equal to I
don't really care so I'm just going to
leave that as it is okay so that leads
me to Part C now here's a fun bit right
for Part C how many of you can I get a
show of hands now how many people have
finished parts 8 yep
what did you notice about Part C that
was interesting have you actually
calculated the answers right did the
answer look familiar
was it not exactly the same as Part B
right now why should that be why should
Part C in Part B actually be the same
well I wonder if I can draw it in a way
that will kind of demonstrate to you
hopefully why it's the same is it
consonants or vowels person I remember
vowels first okay how many vowels did we
say we had four okay so here's my
drawing now for this next question right
$4 first what you're doing for five
continents right is this I'm gonna go a
bit further but is this enough of an
argument for you to see why these two
problems are the same how are you gonna
fill in these numbers you're gonna fill
in the numbers exactly the same way
wrong color exactly the same way you did
before right you're gonna say all four
three two one that's how many vowels
there are but you've over counted
because of repetition right and then
when you have a look at the consonants
you're gonna fill them out in exactly
the same way five four three two one but
you have over counted and you have the
same result okay why should these be the
same well it doesn't matter where you've
actually positioned them you're still
counting up the same number of possible
arrangements within those setups if you
like right it's the same blocks if you
like I've just kind of reshuffled them
okay so are you happy with a B and C are
you okay with your
alright now here's here's where the
rubber really hits the road ok again I'm
gonna ask you to work a little bit but
for Part D here's what I want you to
focus on I want you to come with an
answer but I want you to come up with
another way of restating the question
that will get you to the same answer
I'll tell you right away and probably
this as these can confirm for you as
well you can just check the back of the
book whether your answer is right my
question for you is can you tell it
another way that can help you arrive
there I have three ways I'm gonna show
them all to you by the end hopefully by
the time you guys have gone through
maybe I'll have four five I'd be really
keen to see if someone can come up with
a new way to retell it that gives you a
different expression like this but we'll
end up at the same answer in the end
because it's the same number of ways
okay so I'm gonna sit your loose again
on Part D just focus on this one even if
you haven't done a B or C let's all work
on D together and the important thing is
not the number it's how you tell what's
happening how I explained where these
boxes come from and why I put them there
and why I'm dividing okay so Part D
focus on that I'll give you that three
or four minutes to have a have it go
down let's let's uh let's tie some
threads together I promised I was going
to show you three ways of doing this
question so far and don't feel bad
because I've been I've been doing this
question for years I haven't seen a new
way today but that's okay that's right
working work in it so here's what I'm
going to do and I sort of gave you a
clue at the beginning oh I forgot to ask
something um this was part a right nine
factorial on two factorial 2 factorial
you're arranging nine objects to
repeated to repeated again I made a
point to say I'm not interested in the
number but did anyone go ahead and work
out the number what was it nine thousand
seven hundred and twenty okay great just
gonna follow that in the back of my mind
now the first way that I thought I would
do this is hopefully you remember but in
probability and all your previous
arrangements stuff that an important and
useful strategy is if you are given
conditions sort out the conditions first
and then have a look at all of the other
free stuff afterwards okay so what I can
do is say well I'm interested in the
letter D no letter M okay I don't know
where they are independently but I know
where they are in relation to each other
so I can think about different and some
of you cutting onto this already
different cases for where one of the
letters could be because that will fix
where the other letters could be so for
instance if I think out the first case
let's just put the letter D at the front
where it starts right at this particular
moment where can I place the end because
the N and the D are related to each
other
how many places either to place the end
at the moment I had nine slots at least
I counted nine I have taken one of them
out I have eight slots for the letter M
eight slots for the letter M right and
then I have to place all the rest of the
letters yes how many are the rest of the
letters seven fact or do I care where
they are in relation to each other
no that can be any way we like right and
then of course there's some there's some
repetition that we already know about
from the earlier question so you're
happy with that okay so there's a case
but of course the letter D may not be in
position one it may be in another
position right so if I put it in
position two again I'm gonna think about
that's my first condition my second
condition is that letter n I'm gonna ask
you again how many places can they let
it end go in this person you know this
configuration can the letter n go here
no it can't has to be on the right it
can't be where the letter D already is
so there are seven spots remaining seven
spots for where the letter n can go okay
now let me for example let's let's place
it somewhere let's place it here it
could be there that's one of those seven
spots now how many spots are left to
fill up out of how many free slots are
there left there are seven and have to
fill them all right so I'm gonna
multiply by seven factorial again and I
still have that repetition to take care
of okay I'm gonna do this one more and
then hopefully that establishes the
pattern I've looked out for a case for D
being first and second I'm gonna go
third let me ask one more time how many
places can the letter and go at the
moment there are six spots right in fact
I might I could put all of them in right
one two three four five six different
positions right so I'm placing a single
object it has six choices but there
as in all the other ones I still have
those remaining seven letters to place
are you okay with that so I'm gonna
multiply by seven factorial and then I'm
gonna take care of the repetition have
we established a pattern we established
a pattern every time you've got to take
care of the repetition every time you
have to place the other seven letters in
some places that you don't care and then
there's the D and the N which we've
sorted out by these cases right so if I
add all of these up
what can I factorize out what's in
common between all of them the seven
factorial is in common because you've
got to place seven of those letters you
don't care where they are the the two
factorial 2 factorial is also in common
because you always have this repetition
then you've got to look out for but then
what I multiply by I now have to add all
of these why am i adding this to this to
this and not multiplying its cases yes
why don't we add cases and not multiply
them right it's that same idea before
right like the D said previously we had
simultaneous things like you need the
consonants and the vowels but here it's
like you can't have the letter D in the
first place and the second place these
are mutually exclusive do you agree so
that's why I'm adding them not
multiplying them so here comes the first
case and then the second case and then
the etc all the way down to the last
case does that make sense
now I think if we do this if my memory
serves we should get forty five thousand
three hundred and sixty did we get that
calculate have confirmed okay wonderful
okay there's a way to tell it and
probably a you're okay with that I'm
okay with that that's not a bad solution
we got the correct answer at the bottom
but I'm not satisfied okay because if I
do this the first time how can I
convince myself that that is true right
well I want another way to get to the
same answer okay